there's a professor at rutgers right now
she just went on a
show the root
and
this rutgers professor was pontificating
about white people about race and
society and uh to cut to the chase
she unlike white people very much
i think that white people are committed
to being villains in the aggregate right
the real sort of issue here you know
i've heard people sort of say it is
one i think that white people viscerally
fear it's not that white people don't
know right what they have done they know
they fear that there is no other way to
be human but the way in which they are
human which is to so you know like you
talk to white people and whenever you
really want to have a reckoning about it
they say stuff like you know it's just
human nature if y'all had all of this
power you would have done the same thing
right
and it's like no that's what white
humans did white human beings thought
there's a world here and we own it prior
to them black and brown people have been
sailing across oceans interacting with
each other for centuries without total
subjugation domination and colonialism i
do think that all of us can sort of
agree that our politics that says like
there are superior and inferior human
beings just isn't the way to go and
that's the thing that white people don't
trust us to do because they are so
corrupt you know their thinking is so
morally and spiritually bankrupt about
power
it's wrong to say that some people are
better than other people you know you
know that's wrong
and you know who does that those
corrupt evil villainous smelly dirty
rotten awful white people they all those
horrible disgusting filthy cockroach
white people they say that some people
are better than others you know man i
hate those white people that was awful
so from the historical perspective what
this lunatic is saying is just not true
she's saying that before european
colonization and exploration
black people
untouched by the evil white man had been
sailing across oceans and living in sort
of some sort of edenic paradise none of
that is true i don't i look i know they
say christopher columbus discovered
america some people say it was leif
eriksen but
i i don't i don't think anyone is
claiming that someone from sub-saharan
africa who had never met the evil awful
white man actually discovered america or
something like that right so that is
that is not the case and in that if they
had they would not have engaged in
colonialism or imperialism or anything
everyone would have lived in kumbaya
that's not even true in africa right i
mean what is at the heart of this crazy
racial politics is the slave trade
and colonialism and imperialism as she's
alluding to we'll get to that in one
second first though i am thrilled to
introduce a very very timely app that
you were going to want to get this very
second get upside
what is getupside getupside allows you
to make up to 25 cents for every gallon
of gas every time you fill up you
download the free get upside app in the
app store or google play right now you
use promo code knowles know w-l-e-s you
get a bonus 25 cents per gallon on your
first fill up that means up to 50 cents
cash back per gallon do not pay full
price at the pump anymore get cash back
using get upside down load the app for
free and use promo code knowles k w l e
s to get up to 50 cents per gallon cash
back on your first tank some people who
drive a lot
are making as much as two to three
hundred dollars a month in cash
there is no catch
the cash gets
right added to your bank account it can
be put through paypal it can be put
through an e-gift card for amazon or
other brands super simple don't leave
money on the table download the free get
upside app use promo code no scanner
wles to get up to 50 cents per gallon
cashback on your first tank that is code
knowles where did that slave trade come
from did it come because the white man
showed up in africa and then just threw
a big net on people and just took them
away no there was a pre-existing slave
trade in africa
among africans
a lot of it was controlled actually by
north africans but there was a huge
slave trade in sub-saharan africa
there still is slavery in africa to this
very day
so historically that doesn't make any
sense but
what whatever who cares i mean this
lunatic professor who probably shouldn't
have graduated high school is now
teaching students i'm sure she has
advanced degrees and she's pushing the
same kind of ridiculous racial nonsense
that that goes back to this professor
leonard jeffries
you you sometimes hear this from people
like nick cannon or other black
nationalist types that the white people
are villains they're just evil they're
just so corrupt they're spiritually
bankrupt
and the black people are good and the
white people are the ice people and the
black people are the sun people i mean
this this kind of craziness has actually
been taught for a number of decades but
my point is actually even outside of the
academy
my point is this
on a political level we are told
that
white people are the absolute top of the
privilege hierarchy they are the
oppressors
they can do no wrong they get all the
special privileges
we are told that men are the very tippy
top we are told that straight people are
the very tippy top we're told that
cisgender people people who know what
sex they are they're at the very tippy
top
and yet
could you say these sorts of things in
public
about any other race
of course not you could not go out and
make a bunch of disparaging comments
about black people and call them
villains and call them
murderers and call them evil and
spiritually bankrupt and corrupt you
couldn't do that you would be ostracized
you'd be certainly fired from your
teaching job you'd be ostracized you
might be charged with some kind of hate
crime you couldn't do it about asian
people you couldn't do it about hispanic
people
you could only do it about white people
because what we are told
is that white people are the most
powerful dominant group in the whole
world who can get away with anything but
in fact they're the only race of people
that you're publicly allowed to and
actually encouraged to criticize
and taught that should be abolished
right we need to abolish whiteness we
need to eradicate whiteness
obviously you couldn't say that about
any other race same is true on sex
you're not allowed to criticize women
you are almost obligated to criticize
men
same is true on sexual desire you're not
allowed to criticize homosexuals or
polyamorous people or transgender people
or any you're not allowed to raise any
question about these things that could
get you
criticized banned ostracized
charged with a hate crime but you can do
that to straight people the
the reality
of
hierarchy
in the country
is radically different from what we are
told the hierarchy is according to the
intersectional left critical race theory
the gender ideology it's actually
the opposite
did you like that clip
i i liked that clip as well i liked that
you liked it if you want to get these
notifications you've got to ring the
bell and subscribe you still probably
won't get notifications because some
people around here don't
particularly care for our show
youtube
but you can also subscribe at apple
podcast but if i stitch your google play
wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe to the michael knowles show
click that button maybe leave a five
star review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you